MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
CONFIRMATION BATTLE OVER BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
THE WHITE HOUSE GIVING THE FBI
THE GO-AHEAD TO EXPAND ITS
INVESTIGATION OF THE
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE BY
INTERVIEWING ANYBODY HE DEEMS
NECESSARY.
THIS IS, THE BUREAUS PROBE COULD
WRAP UP AS EARLY AS TOMORROW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP STANDING BY HIS
NOMINEE IN LIGHT OF THE LATEST
FDA REVIEW.
>> THIS IS THEIR SEVENTH
INVESTIGATION.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY ARE JUST
STARTING.
I WANT THEM TO DO A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS ACCORDING TO
THE SENATORS AND THE REPUBLICANS
AND THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY.
I WANT THEM TO DO THAT.
I WANTED TO BE COMPREHENSIVE.
I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S A GOOD
THING FOR JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I WOULD
LIKE IT TO GO QUICKLY.
THE REASON I WOULD LIKE IT TO GO
QUICKLY, VERY SIMPLE.
IT'S SO SIMPLE BIRD BECAUSE IT'S
UNFAIR TO HIM AT THIS POINT.
>> Jesse: AFTER DEMANDING THE
FBI PROBE, DEMOCRATS ARE
PREDICTABLY COMPLAINING IT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH.
>> BASED ON SOME OF THE REPORTS
WE'VE SEEN I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THE
WHITE HOUSE SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO MICROMANAGE AN FBI
INVESTIGATION.
>> THERE IS TIME.
THE THING IS, EVERY SENATE VOTE
MATTERS AND THERE'S TIME TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT EVEN IF IT
IS SEVEN DAYS.
THAT'S BAD ENOUGH BUT THEN TO
LIMIT THE FBI AS TO THE SCHOOL
BAND WHO THEY'RE GOING TO
QUESTION.
>> Jesse: THE ARIZONA
PROSECUTOR WE SAW AT THE HEARING
LAST WEEK IS DEALING A BLOW TO
DEMOCRATS.
RACHEL MITCHELL DETAILS IN A
MEMO WHY SHE WOULD NOT BRING
CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST
KAVANAUGH, SAYING IT'S EVEN
WEAKER THAN "HE SAID-SHE SAID."
DANA, YOU MISSED THIS, ON
VACATION.
>> Dana: I KEPT TABS ON IT A
LITTLE BIT.
THEY HAVE A THING CALLED WI-FI
IN SPAIN.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY REMARKABLE, THE
WEEK.
I SAID TO GREG I CAN'T BELIEVE I
MISSED THE WEEK.
HE SAID THAT'S A OKAY.
NEXT WEEK WILL BE WORSE.
HERE WE ARE.
SO EXTREMELY COMPELLING ANSWER
INTERESTING POLLING CAME OUT
TODAY FROM QUINNIPIAC SAYING 40%
OF PEOPLE POLLED, VOTERS POLLED,
SAID THEY DID NOT THINK HE
SHOULD BE CONFIRMED.
42 PERCENT DID.
BUT 56% THINK HE'S -- THIS IS
PART OF A POLITICAL SMEAR
CAMPAIGN.
I CAN'T REMEMBER THE OTHER
NUMBER.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE SOME MORE
POLLING ON THIS.
THERE ARE BASICALLY FOUR CENTERS
THIS COMES DOWN TO.
MURKOWSKI, FLAKE, COLLINS, AND
MANCHIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN
WEST VIRGINIA.
THERE IS INCREDIBLE PRESSURE ON
SENATOR MANCHIN BECAUSE HIS
CONSTITUENTS, A NUMBER THAT'S
ASTRONOMICAL, WANT BRETT
KAVANAUGH TO BE CONFIRMED.
I THINK A RISK PER BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S NOMINATION THIS WEEK
IS THAT NOW THAT THE HEARING IS
DONE, NOW WE HAVE THIS FBI
INVESTIGATION, AS YOU SAID,
DEMOCRATS SAYING THAT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH.
SENATOR McCONNELL SAYING TODAY
WE WILL VOTE THIS WEEK.
IN THE MEANTIME, YOU BASICALLY
HAVE DEAD AIR PER BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPEAKING SO
PASSIONATELY ABOUT HIS NOMINEE
TODAY FROM THE ROSE GARDEN HELPS
FILL THE GAP A LITTLE BIT BUT
THE NEWS CYCLE MOVE SO FAST.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A RALLY
TONIGHT AND HE'S GOT ONE
TOMORROW.
HOW LONG CAN HE KEEP IT GOING?
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE NOMINEE
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP TO KEEP IT
IN THE NEWS ON THEIR TERMS.
>> Jesse: HE IS HIGH-ENERGY
ENOUGH.
I THINK YOU CAN FILL THE VOID.
THIS MITCHELL REPORT, EMILY,
THAT CAME OUT.
SHE WAS NONPARTISAN SEX CRIMES
PROSECUTOR WHO REPUBLICANS
BROUGHT IN.
SHE RELEASED A LETTER THAT SAID
SOME INTERESTING THINGS THAT SHE
WOULD NEVER, EVER BRING CHARGES
IN A CASE LIKE THIS AND IT'S
INCREDIBLY WEAK FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
>> Emily: MULTIPLE THINGS
ABOUT THE REPORT.
FIRST OF ALL, WE ARE ALREADY
HEARING BACKLASH THAT SHE SHOULD
MENDED A REPORT WHICH I FIND
PREPOSTEROUS.
WHAT IS SHE GOING TO DO?
TEXT FROM THE PLANE?
THIS WAS OUTSOURCED BY THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
REPUBLICANS FOR HER TO DO A JOB.
OF COURSE SHE'S GOING TO ISSUE A
REPORT.
I'M ALSO HEARING A LOT OF
BACKLASH FROM OTHER PROSECUTOR
SAYING THIS WASN'T A PROPER
INVESTIGATION AND THAT'S NOT THE
APPROPRIATE STANDARD.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS SHE DID THE
ABSOLUTE BEST WITH WHAT SHE WAS
GIVEN AND THE INVESTIGATION IN
THAT CLOSED WORLD.
SHE USED A PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE STANDARD WHICH IS THE
LOWEST.
TO BRING CHARGES AS A
PROSECUTOR, THE STANDARD FOR
THAT IS THAT YOU HAVE REASONABLE
BELIEF THAT THE CHARGES ARE
SUPPORTED BY PROBABLE CAUSE.
AND THEN ALSO ADMISSIBLE
EVIDENCE SUPPORTED AND IT'S IN
THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE.
SHE USED THE LOWEST POSSIBLE
STANDARD, GETTING THE LOWEST BAR
TO CROSS SO FAR TO INSUFFICIENT.
I FOUND THE REPORT DETAILING AND
THAT SHE SHOULD BE GIVEN MORE
CREDENCE THAN SHE IS.
>> Jesse: ARE THE DEMOCRATS
OUT OF BULLETS?
WE'VE HAD HEARING AFTER HEARING
GRADY HAS PRODUCED MORE
DOCUMENTS AND ANSWERED MORE
QUESTIONS THAN ANY SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE IN HISTORY AND NOW WE
HAVE A SEVENTH FBI BACKGROUND
CHECK.
IS IT GOING TO BE ENOUGH?
>> Juan: CHECK YOUR HISTORY.
WE'VE HAD LONGER CONFIRMATION
BATTLES IN OUR HISTORY.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING HERE, I'M
AMAZED AT WHAT YOU JUST SAID
ABOUT THIS PROSECUTOR FROM
ARIZONA NOT BEING PARTISAN.
SHE WAS BROUGHT IN BECAUSE THEY
WERE ALL MALE REPUBLICANS AND
SHE WAS BROUGHT IN BY THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE, I DEFINITION --
>> Jesse: DOES THAT MAKE HER
PARTISAN?
>> Juan: YES, IT DIES.
AS I RECALL, LINDSEY GRAHAM CUT
HER OFF BECAUSE HE THOUGHT SHE
WASN'T BEING EFFECTIVE AND NOW
SHE DECIDED SHE'S GOING TO
REDEEM HERSELF WITH THE
REPUBLICAN BUDDIES BY ISSUING
THIS REPORT WHICH HAS NO
STANDING BECAUSE IT WASN'T BASED
ON ANY KIND OF INVESTIGATION
BASED ON WHAT SHE WAS ABLE TO
GATHER AT THE HEARING.
>> Jesse: THE KEY POINT FROM
DEMOCRATS, THE DEAL LIKE THIS
WOMAN AND SHE DID A NICE JOB.
GENTLE AND PROFESSIONAL.
>> Juan: THE DEMOCRATS.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, THE KEY
POINT IS YOU LOOK AT THE POLL
NUMBERS THAT DANA REFERRED TO.
LOOK AT THE FOX POLLING,
QUINNIPIAC, YOU LOOK AT HARRIS,
HARVARD, IT'S ALL THE SAME.
PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE KAVANAUGH.
THEY DO BELIEVE HER.
>> Dana: NO, THAT'S NOT --
THAT'S NOT --
THAT WASN'T THE QUESTION.
UNLESS YOU SAW A DIFFERENT POLL.
THAT WAS NOT THE QUESTION ASKED.
>> Juan: THE FOX POLL HAS
50 PERCENT DO NOT CONFIRM.
36% [BLEEP]
BELIEVE FORD
, NOT KAVANAUGH.
IT'S BECOME TRIBAL.
YOU SEE AN UPTICK IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE BACKING KAVANAUGH.
THEY DIDN'T ACT KAVANAUGH TO THE
EXTENT THEY BACKED NEIL GORSUCH.
THIS IS NOT A POPULAR NOMINEE.
IN THE MIDST OF THE TRIBAL
WARFARE, IT TAKES UP.
IT TAKES UP AMONG DEMOCRATS AS
WELL.
THE KEY QUESTION FOR ME, IN
TERMS OF WHEN WE GO FORWARD,
WHAT'S THE STANDARD?
NOW THERE'S FOUR PEOPLE WHO KNEW
KAVANAUGH EITHER IN HIGH SCHOOL
OR COLLEGE AND THEY ARE SAYING
HE WASN'T FORTHCOMING AND
TRUTHFUL ABOUT HIS DRINKING.
IF YOU HOLD TO THE STANDARD, AND
I ARE GOING TO GET DEMOCRATS
WERE GOING TO SAY THIS IS A
MATTER OF CHARACTER FOR SOMEONE
WE ARE PUTTING ON THE COURT FOR
A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT AND WAS
LYING ABOUT WINKING.
>> Jesse: NO ONE LIED ABOUT
DRINKING.
YOU WANT TO USE THE DRINKING
STANDARD, TED KENNEDY COMES TO
MIND.
>> Greg: I HATE THAT WE ARE
USING POLLING TO GAUGE SOMEONE'S
INNOCENCE.
THIS IS NOT A JOB INTERVIEW.
THIS IS NOW THE COLISEUM IN
WHICH WE TURN TO THE CROWD, GAVE
THE THUMBS-UP OR THUMBS DOWN.
THEY DIDN'T JUST MOVE THE
GOALPOST HERE.
THEY TURNED OVER THE GAMEBOARD
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THEY WERE IN
TROUBLE.
IF HE IS LYING ABOUT BOOZE, WHAT
ELSE IS HE LYING ABOUT ARGUMENT
COMETH CLEAR DR. FORD LIED ABOUT
A NUMBER OF THINGS AS WELL.
YOU CAN CALL THEM
INCONSISTENCIES.
THAT'S THE POLITE WAY OF SAYING
LIES.
WHETHER IT WAS ABOUT PLANE
TRAVEL.
SHE ONLY HAS A FEAR OF FLYING
WHEN IT'S NOT ON VACATION.
THE POLYGRAPH.
SHE WASN'T SURE WHEN IT WAS.
SHE SAID IT WAS A DEVASTATING
EXPERIENCE BUT THERE WERE TWO
QUESTIONS.
THE CLAIM THAT SHE NEVER GOT AN
OFFER FROM THE REPUBLICANS, LIKE
GRASSLEY, TABLET MEETING OVER
THERE.
GIVING NOTES TO REPORTERS.
CHANGING BYSTANDER TO NOT
BYSTANDER.
I WILL BE DIPLOMATIC AND SAY
THERE'S A LOT OF INCONSISTENCIES
TO HER OTHERWISE CREDIBLE
TESTIMONY.
THAT IS HOW YOU TALK APPARENTLY.
IF HIS LIES ABOUT BOOZE, WHICH I
DO BELIEVE HE FIBBED ABOUT HIS
DRINKING BECAUSE HE'S TALKING
ABOUT HIS DRINKING IN FRONT OF
HIS WIFE AND KIDS.
I AM SORRY.
I DO THE SAME THING.
WHEN MY WIFE ASKS ME HOW MUCH I
DRANK OVER THE WEEKEND WHILE
SHE'S AWAY I SAY NOT MUCH,
HONEY.
SHE SAYS YEAH, RIGHT.
THOSE LIES HAVE NOTHING TO DO
THE ACTUAL ACCUSATION BUT SINCE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ALCOHOL
ABUSE, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE OBVIOUSLY
ALCOHOLICS BECAUSE THEY
COMPLETELY BLACKED OUT THE LAST
FIVE DAYS.
THEY DO NOT REMEMBER THAT THE
THIRD ACCUSER HAS A HISTORY OF
LYING AND SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
CLAIMS, LYING ABOUT HER
EMPLOYMENT, LYING ABOUT HER
EDUCATION.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO REMEMBER THE
AVENATTI BOMBSHELL FROM LAST
WEEK WHICH IS NOW THE BOMBED
SHELL THAT SHE LIED ABOUT HER
BACKGROUND.
THEY BLACKED OUT ABOUT THE
RACHEL MITCHELL MEMO.
WE ARE COVERING IT.
THE ONLY REASON WE ARE COVERING
IT, BECAUSE NO ONE ELSE'S
BECAUSE THEY BLACKED OUT.
THESE ARE HUGE THINGS THAT THE
MEDIA CANNOT REMEMBER BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO REMEMBER IT.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> Juan: YOU LISTEN TO THE
PRESIDENT TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
IS NOW ENGAGING IN JUST THE KIND
OF ANGRY BULLYING BEHAVIOR.
CORY BOOKER.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Juan: RICHARD BLUMENTHAL IS
A LIAR COME ALL THESE DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE NOT ANGELS OVER THERE.
>> Greg: ISN'T THAT GREAT?
>> Juan: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
A SUPREME COURT NOMINEE.
TOTALLY DENIGRATING THE WHOLE
PROCESS.
>> Greg: UNCORROBORATED
ACCUSATIONS.
DESTROYING A PERSON'S LIFE.
AND UNCORROBORATED ACCUSATION.
>> Juan: YOU ARE FOCUSING AS
IF THIS IS JUST ABOUT KAVANAUGH.
>> Greg: THIS IS ALL IT'S
ABOUT.
YOU ARE WILLING TO DESTROY
SOMEBODY OVER A SEAT.
YOU CAN HAVE THE SEAT.
>> Juan: I HAVE BULLETS AND ME
FROM TRYING TO DEFEND SOMEONE
WHEN I THOUGHT THEY WERE BEING
UNFAIRLY MALIGNED.
I WILL TELL YOU WHEN YOU LOOK AT
KAVANAUGH, YOU JUST SAID YOU
THINK HE IS FIBBING ABOUT THE
DRINKING.
YOU HAVE TO SPEAK TO A MAN OR
WOMAN'S CHARACTER, PUTTING THEM
IN CHARGE >> Greg: A GUY
TRYING TO PLAY DOWN THE BEER.
>> Juan: IN THE YEARBOOK, YOU
HAVE SOMETHING ABOUT THE DEVILS
TRIANGLE.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE SELLING
BOOKS WHILE WE WERE GOING OVER
ALL OF THAT.
THE DEVILS TRIANGLE IS A